[Musique]
je m'appelle Jean-Claude delgard donc je
suis animateur au
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
G qu'est-ce que ça fait d'être un
animateur dans un espace naturel
sensible mon métier consiste en fait bah
comme le nom l'indique l'appellation
garde donc je fais aussi bien des
missions de police de
l'environnement on intervient sur aussi
bien sur les sites quelques sites du
département et les sites du
Conservatoire littoral et puis ben la
grosse mission principale c'est
l'animation c'està-dire que nous en fait
il y a en fait la plein d'écoles
viennent nous voir et on monte des
projets pédagogiques aussi bien avec le
petit public lescolairire école primaire
collège
lycée est-ce que c'est important de
partager vos connaissances avec
nous on fait passer un message donc le
message c'est bah vous êtes dans une
dans un hot spot de on va dire dans un
lieu de biodiversité il y a une fun une
Flor exceptionnelle et bah c'est les
aider en fait à ouvrir regarder cette
cette richesse là et de dire ben voilà
il faut faire attention bah la Réunion
il y a des espècesces qui ne vivent que
qu'ici et ben si on ne fait rien si on
les protège pas si on les respecte pas
bah d'ici quelques années ils sont
amenés à
disparaître
est-ce que vous pouvez nous raconter
l'histoire de cet espace naturel
sensible de sans
souci sur sans souci la particularité de
cette uns il y a aussi bien le
patrimoine culturel donc présence de
Boucan dû au passé donc à la culture du
géranium et un patrimoine naturel qu'on
a vu ce matin avec les élèves c'estàd
qu'on a c'est le seul ons de lî on va
traverser trois étages de végétation la
forêt semi-sèche la forêt de bois de
couleur des bas là on est donc on est au
niveau de la forêt de bois de couleur
desbas aux alentours et puis plus haut
la forêt de bois de couleur des haut et
ici donc on peut retrouver des espèces
rares on va dire comme le bois jaune le
bois puyant donc qui sont vraiment au
niveau des au niveau des ravines quoi au
niveau des falaises
[Musique]
quoi alors ça y est on est arrivé donc à
je vais ouvrir la porte d'un des bouquin
donc le bouquin du du gsep conservatoire
de la Réunion alors un bouquin donc
c'est ce que vous voyez là-bas en fait
hein alors qu'est-ce que c'est qu'un
bouquin
c'est on va dire une petite case sous
tool donc à l'époque qu'utilisait donc
les les planteurs de géranium en fait il
restait sur site ça allit de quelques
jours à 3 mois pour en fait cultiver le
géranium donc c'est on va dire sur le
site on a 32 boucans ça part d'ici puis
ça monte jusqu'à on va dire la partie
haute voilà donc je vous invite à venir
et on va déjeuner faire une pause au
niveau du
boucan est-ce que il faut être passionné
de la nature pour être
animateur si on n'est pas on nime pas la
randonnée on naime
pas la nature on n'est pas sensibilisé
je pense qu' c'est il faut un minimum
quoi donc moi je ça fait plus de 10 ans
que je suis dans le métier donc j'ai été
ancien animateur nature sur la réserve
de la roche écrite ensuite ben on a je
suis arrivé au au GSP donc depuis de les
années 2000 2009 puis jusqu'à maintenant
donc et puis je me suis plus j'ai élargi
mon champ de compétence donc j'ai vu
qu'il y avait une formation avec laath
donc l'atelier technique des espac
Naturels Sensibles basé à Montpellier en
métropole qui proposait donc bah de se
spécialiser dans la police de
l'environnement quoi donc voilà donc
c'est tout nouveau pour pour moi mais je
en fait j'allis les deux aussi bien les
missions de d'animation donc éducation
l'environnement et aussi bien les
missions de de police sur le terrain et
puis bah on se serait enfin on se porte
volontiers pour vous faire visiter C ces
richesses en fait que offre notre île de
la Réunion quoi
voilà c'est
tout
[Musique]